on your website Jason Horton TV com
looks like you encourage visitors to
sign up for the mainland yes and you
offer exclusive videos so how do those
videos differ those exclusive ones from
the ones that are just on the regular
YouTube channel you I could love it's
behind the scenes short little short
little videos I'm just trying to not
have people rely on youtube to see to
see might see my stuff you know I try to
find have my own sites and things so if
you to goes down for the day you know it
does I mean it's a you know it's a
machine um and this humans working it I
still want people to see see my stuff so
I just give him another play I'm just
really it's really to encourage people
to go to another site it's hard it's
hard to you know you when you put up a
put up a video you can't be like go here
and also go here and also their security
you know it's it's almost like now I'm
just gonna go nowhere I'm gonna walk
away so I'm just slowly trying to drive
traffic over to my own website I don't
really do a lot with that right now
because uh yeah you know certain things
that I'm working on but I'm always kind
of making that making that transfer to
hopefully have everything hosted on
there as well and so it's not just
YouTube like if YouTube you know went
away I like you know a place for people
to go to see what I do right but keeping
with that sort of marketing mind um what
are you hoping to gain by getting their
email address do you plan to do a
newsletter or do you already do news I
haven't done I actually I hate
newsletters I hate getting them but I
don't hate people from doing them
because I totally understand and you
know it not everyone is me so I don't
really like to it sweet funny it's like
I'm i love promoting myself but i don't
like bothering people I really really
don't uh everyone's busy and stuff like
that but there's a certain amount to say
hey listen I have something I hope you
like it and you know an email list and
people can I unsubscribe from email
lists all the time you know it's that
easy so I'm hoping to you know kind of
have that look I have email list for
like hey people this demographic blogs
you like these kind of videos I do
whether it's like my kind of
like relationship daily stuff the kind
of adult star stuff they do with my
podcast so I have those so I'll send
them out in an email going hey if you
want to pick this up and use it great
let me know and I'll promote it you know
it it's up by myself it's hard for me to
rely could probably get someone to do
that for me but it's just a slow process
of kind of owning your audience why so
is it like sort of that night he's
method where you can enter the site but
can you please just enter your info
first or do you do it where it's a
sidebar or someone um it's it's
encouraging people to it's encouraging
people to leave their at least leave
their email you know where it's not so
much like you're signing up for this
it's like well you left your email
voluntarily you know baby i'll email you
not very often about some new new stuff
I get out I mean there used to be like
websites kind of I feel like went away
and I feel like they're coming back at
least that's what in my conversations
with people in the know websites are
coming back like Smosh is the most
subscribed youtube channel their website
is like an entity you know if it's they
generate a lot from their website not
super familiar but I know that they they
do that that's in a very important part
of their big picture
you